(gentle instrumental music)
- [Franklin] Every year we
lose about 20, 30 species
that are gone forever,
and using this technology,
I think that we can preserve
and save those species
that have been lost.
- [Narrator] Scientists at
the University of Georgia
are attempting to use
DNA from endangered cats
to save them from extinction.
- [Franklin] What we're trying
to do here is collect skin cells
from endangered species
and actually turn them
into sperm or eggs.
- [Narrator] The goal is
to develop a tiger embryo
and artificially inseminate a house cat,
which will then give
birth to a baby tiger.
Because of the extensive knowledge
of domestic cats' reproductive systems,
the risk of failure is significantly lower
than if using a tiger as a surrogate.
- We know that we're gonna
have a lot of hurdles
and so what we wanna do is start off
with an animal we know very well,
and so we thought cats
was a good starting point.
(lively instrumental music)
- [Narrator] The three-part process
of creating an artificial embryo begins
with collecting skin cell
samples from endangered species.
- [Franklin] We got these
samples from Zoo Atlanta.
They collected the biopsies
from their Sumatran tiger
and their clouded leopard.
- [Narrator] Those skin
cells are then turned
into stem cells, which
will later be reprogrammed
into sperm and eggs, allowing
for the creation of an embryo.
- Once we have the sperm and eggs,
we'll combine them together,
we'll get a developing embryo,
and then the idea is
we're gonna transfer them
into a domestic cat,
and hopefully in a few months,
we'll have a number of
kittens from that individual.
(gentle instrumental music)
- [Narrator] One of
the greatest challenges
that the team has faced has
been developing the technique
to transform skin cells into stem cells,
a necessary task that they
have yet to accomplish.
- [Franklin] We are still
waiting to make that leap
from skin cell to stem cell,
and I think we're finally on the doorstep.
We're ready to go.
(gentle instrumental music)
- [Narrator] By collecting
and freezing skin cell samples
from various animals,
scientists are effectively
providing a road to bringing back species
that may become extinct in the future.
- In a single tank, you
could have a biobank
of two, 300 different species
and enough individuals
in each box where you
could use this technology
to repopulate lost species.
I'll never give up essentially,
you know, as long as I can
keep doing great science
and exciting things;I just
really think endangered species
are important to conserve,
and they're worth the effort.